hallo meine lieben freunde ich darf ich
heute recht herzlich willkommen heißen
endlich mal wieder zu einer nichte
lachen challenge ohne sandra
deswegen richtig auch nicht nach kippen
es ist eine taube
als er plötzlich doch irgendwas
[Applaus]
[Musik]
stellen wurde denkst dir europa das eine
taube ich geb dir jetzt mal hoch film
das ganze und hinter die crashen auto
der garage
ganz normaler dienstag
[Musik]
oh mein gott stelle war seit aufgehalten
und die kann doch eine ratte
[Musik]
was
war
der termin liege die darum kräht alter
eine möwe gopro und
alter aber das sind dann so videos alter
diese inhalt krass weil dieses ganze
gopro irgendwo hinstellen auf den server
damit sind sie beim surf ist einfach
scheiße
dass es gibt nichts langweiligeres
generell finde ich diese ganzen gopro
compilations von wegen people und jemand
springt mit einem paraglider in den berg
runter fliegt durch irgendwelche
hindurch und dann irgendwie ein typ der
70 es macht immer wenn ich mir angucke
denke ich mir nur so
gutes video
gar nicht wie krass dieser aufnahmen
eigentlich sind
was ist sie was ist das im mund was ist
ich habe viele fragen
die ersten stücke
und wie kann damit
essen also jeder das machen was er will
mit seinem körper oder das tragen was er
möchte da keine ahnung was aber das
verstehe ich wirklich nicht es ist doch
das ist doch nur unpraktisch da bin ich
blöd aber ich verstehe auch keine
ohrringe da also ich wäre so ein mensch
wenn nicht so große ohrringe hätte und
ich würde dieses jahres angehen wie man
daraus ziehen oh
du mein freund
mein handy beim lachen runtergefallen
das ist aber kein problem denn ich hab
eine hülle
spaß beiseite freude ich freue mich
wirklich übertrieben dass die heutige
nicht lachen challenge freundlicherweise
unterstützt wird von rhein und spiel
denn ihr wisst ja dass weitere schilder
ich schon seit jahren zusammenarbeiten
das ist wie so eine beziehung weil kommt
auch heiratsantrag gleich könnt euch
noch an dieses video von vor einigen
jahren erinnern wo wir ca alles mit
meinem iphone angestellt haben was man
so machen kann tragischerweise hatte ich
allerdings vor zwei wochen keine rein
und hülle um meine ernährung und das ist
mir natürlich runtergefallen ist es
komplett début vorne geht zwar noch
allerdings hat der rheinische trotzdem
sagt mir ein stück für den 19 wir
schicken die direkt neue case so ein
spiel protektoren zu und die haben echte
menge im angebot sind reine schied ist
nicht einfach nur irgendeine handy höhen
brand sondern mittlerweile wirklich viel
viel mehr rein schildert nämlich nicht
nur schlichte handy cases sondern steckt
noch extrem viel arbeit und farbenfroh
designs und dabei arbeiten sie mit
vielen leuten zusammen aus filmen gaming
anime aus verschiedenen szenen und haben
beispielsweise vier marvel designs wir
haben wir die ganzen höhen schon runter
arbeitsgruppe von renault wir haben hier
ein case mit einem nasa design wir haben
hier bunte sachen wir haben sachen aus
der anime szene hiermit bisschen so
pixel art drauf hier mit wolken also die
arbeiten wirklich krass daran dass die
höhlen zu einem modischen produkt
gemacht werden welche eure interessen
und vor allem euren persönlichen stil
widerspiegeln checkt also rein rangiert
jetzt auf jeden fall gern mal ab alle
weiteren infos und links dazu findet ihr
in der infobox mit dem kot luca alte
tier zum thema noch auf 15 prozent
online
sondern
jetzt bin ich im auto war schon dass ich
irgendwie auch viel zu selten mache
ich glaub ich bin aber perfekte geil
bild von sandra ich glaube ich bin eine
einzige der bei saucen groß einfach
überhaupt nicht lachen muss
generell ich sage euch ab jetzt werde
ich einfach gar nicht mehr lachen
[Musik]
etwas in rachen
das bin ich beim passen aber was ist das
ist colin
hay
alle die mir auf instagram folgen
wissen dass ich auch ein paar tagen
unfall hat habe ich nicht dran schuld
war
ich stehe einfach an der ampel habe ich
auch schon im podcast erzählt ich stehe
an einer ampel und urplötzlich denkt
sich so ein audi vor mir a perfect egal
wir fahren los die ampel wird grünig
fahrbahn rückwärtsgang
nur blöd dass ich da war
[Applaus]
ich schwöre euch jedes mal in letzter
zeit auch wenn ich mir essen bestelle
die bringen das dann hier hin ich nehme
das und ich pack das in meiner küche aus
und alles ist ausgelaufen
letzten sich bestellen überteuerten
smoothie weil ich mir dachte bord kommen
fühlt sich nicht nur die für 5 euro bild
erhält der ganze suchen sie hat einfach
nur meine einkaufstasche
das sind probleme
so
zurecht noch mal ein kick hinterher
auch zu recht da noch mal die tür
aggressive aufgemacht denn erst wenn ihr
euren frust einfach in sachen auslass
dieser gar nichts für könne ein dicker
und haben dann geht es runter gefragt
[Musik]
hey
so blöd machen wir zündung land ist in
diesem musste vorglühen
[Musik]
junge
mein humor
ist einfach auf dem mond
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was ich erwarte dass die
ganze zeit zurückspulen mit der
saugglocke
das ist
also ja der job auf war die mit den mit
dem ich frage das snap und sie
gekoppelten kopf aber was
ich habe das nicht oft genug am gucken
so was habe ich noch nie gesehen also
generell das hier ist schon stark und
dann
ganz kurze
ich glaube ich muss keinem erklären wie
krank schwierig das ist gibt es noch
eine reaktion darauf
dass
der letzte club
und an der stelle mich dass heute ich
will jetzt auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch die heutige nicht
lachen scheint gefallen hat dann einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke weitere videos nicht verpassen
wollte ich bin ja hier einerseits wieder
voll aktiv und auch auf beim zweit kanal
lupu könnte einfach mal bei youtube
eingeben dort kommen aktuell nahezu
täglich irgendwelche videos von mir
solche reactions online weil ich hier
eigentlich nicht so viel action machen
möchte allerdings nicht lange denn das
sind immer noch ganz geil und die möchte
ich gern selber stelle auf meinem
zweiten stein kumpel freiheit die fresse
du laden